1986 the broncos and the giants played a
regular season game the giants won 19 to
16. who scored the only touchdown that
day
for the new york giants oh i mean are
you guys kidding me coming with that
crap
you'd really think i won't know this i
mean come on
i i mean i might know every play the
whole season
without even asking me george martin
throw to the right
john elway thinks he's gonna hit the
back out of the backfield
george martin sticks his big left hand
up there one hand interception
down the left-hand sideline through
elway off of him
runs then the end zone lt grings his
neck and tackles him into the end zone
i mean that was one of the great plays
that was a great game and yeah odd that
you got the super bowl preview
giants had to make uh i think my dad had
a third and
30 something like that and hit a 46 yard
completion to put him in field goal
position to win the game
he was 11 for 20 in that game how much
of what he learned facing the broncos
then allowed him to have
the highest completion percentage ever
in the super bowl when they got together
again well i think the big thing he's
always told me
and and if you go back and watch super
bowl 21 the giants went into
they changed it up you know during that
first matchup they tried to run
and control the clock that way and kind
of play smash mouth football and realize
the hard way that
denver was a little more physical than i
think they expected and when they got in
the super bowl i think denver expected
that same approach from the giants
because that's what they were it was
run the ball with joe morris and then
big phil was going to take big shots
down the field to bavaro and lionel
manuel and company like that that's the
way it worked
well they came out in the super bowl and
they were a throw first football team
and i think that caught denver by
surprise a little bit got dad going
and uh you know the rest is history but
uh special day it was ten nine
at halftime broncos trust me we were
the sims family we definitely were i i
remember it well i was rooting for the
broncos you know what course you were
broncos because you're a jew yeah
because the giants
because the giants beat the vikings that
you're on the regular season they kept
the vikings out of the playoffs that's
right
phil yeah you jerk yep by the way fourth
and seventeen
five years listen chris was five and he
processed all that information and still
remembers it today so my only question
is what the hell happened
35 years since well lots of lots of
retards
a few brain cells not enough deep talks
too much retox all right you get the
first pick
all right um unsung hero i can't believe
i'm gonna do this but i'm gonna pick a
kicker cause i'm gonna go with harrison
butker
of the kansas city chiefs just just
purely from what we saw last week
i know this is a first two weeks of the
season type of thing
but man to not only
he hit a 58 yarder earlier in the game
but then to have to hit it three times
two of which don't count
and then make it that third time in
which it did count
just unbelievable i mean we don't talk
about kickers enough and sometimes how
they can be a weapon to your football
team and he is a great weapon for them
because once they get over midfield
they're kind of in field goal range and
those three kicks he made at the end of
the game
53 58 58 all of them
were perfect none of them had any
hesitation right it was amazing
it was see it happen yeah all right uh
first one for me
is uh james robinson the rookie running
back for the jacksonville jaguars he has
been
incredibly impressive in two games with
the jaguars undrafted
which that isn't unprecedented
for a tailback but he went to illinois
state he didn't go to one of the major
colleges
your role in the dice when you're the
jaguars on an undrafted guy from
illinois state as you're starting
tailback going into week one after you
dump leonard fernette
and he has gotten it done and nobody's
noticed
which i'm sure is fine with him but he's
going to get his chance on thursday
night when the jaguars and the dolphins
get together so if you don't already
know the name
get to know it now because james
robinson has it and
he's getting it done at the nfl level
and he deserves more praise for what
he's accomplished he does
it's a great pick by you he's been
really impressive like past the eye test
almost immediately i think for both of
us where even in week one i was just
like damn
all right this kid yeah he can go a
little bit so
been really impressive can make big
plays
can break some warm tackles and it's
just another story this isn't more
evidence of
this is why some teams don't want to pay
or draft a running back in the first
round and do things like that look at
this guy he didn't even get drafted
and he looks like he could be a go-to
star running back in the league
all right i'm going to go up to green
bay i'm going to go to marquez valdez
scanting
scantling excuse me uh he is so unsung
we can't get his name right
exactly right that's unsung that is
unsung but
but what he's done for that football
team and not that he had to be a
superstar
but we saw in week one stretching the
field out
deep down the field big target for
rogers had a drop
okay whatever but week two same thing
happened
he still established himself as a guy
where now there's two weeks in a row
defenses are going to look at green bay
and go man deovante adams is a pain but
we got to be a little careful with this
83 83
we give them enough chances he's gonna
run by you and rogers is gonna take a
shot to him
i think that's been a great addition
just to have
an official number two in green bay
finally
to where you can go all right there's
some dependability there in the
receiving core
and you know of course the alan lazard
kids helped them out too but but
valdez scantling deserves a lot a lot of
credit
when the chargers let melvin gordon walk
away austin eckler became the starting
running back
and you know nobody pays attention to
chargers they don't have many fans
if they had fans in the stands they
would be fans for the other team but
eckler has been extremely good and he
had a great game against the chiefs
on sunday and he hasn't had a hundred
yard game but he has been
solid and he is exactly what that
running game needs and he is earning
every dollar they've paid him and he is
earning the faith they showed in him by
letting melvin gordon get away so
i think austin eckler a guy who even
though they aren't 2-0
he deserves more praise for what he's
accomplished and he's a guy that we need
to be paying attention to because i
think especially if they go with justin
herbert
and teams are more inclined to try to
take some steam out of the passing game
it's going to make it easier for eckler
to have some bigger rushing totals going
forward
yeah definitely no doubt and you know
you would think too if they went forward
with justin herbert too they'd find more
ways to throw screens to eckler and
maybe make the game a little easier on
herbert and everything like that but
yeah he is some hell of a player he
really is
uh that size speed quickness really has
it all
and he is he's a huge part of their
football team and we don't talk about
him enough
i mean i almost i he's not unsung enough
i was going to go like stefan diggs just
because i think it's been
amazing but i know we'll go
[Music]
guy who gets traded for a first round
pick plus i know he can't be on
here i'm torn between another kicker
which is why i don't really want to do
this
um i'm going to go with jordan reed and
the san francisco 49ers
unsung hero wow what a signing by them
you know
before the year because tight end
position
george kittle very important to shanahan
what they do schematically
his success there jordan reid has been
able to come in get two touchdowns last
week
and fill that void to a degree to where
yeah you got to worry about him he's
super talented i'm glad to see him
having a little success man the guy's
been through it all with the concussions
and everything and
i know he even told you he didn't think
he was going to play football uh or
he was done he was done so we saw the
49ers in the playoffs last year that was
the spark that was when he said i got to
come back i got to come back and he got
reunited with kyle shannon yeah that's
been that's been big and i would think
again that that role continues to be a
big part of their offense again this
week whether kittle plays or not
you know they'll have to be careful with
them because i doubt he would be totally
100
and jordan reid's the perfect guy to
take a little you know the workload off
of kittle
i'm gonna go with calvin ridley the
falcons yeah he has continued to be in
the shadow of julio jones
calvin ridley is awesome and i remember
when calvin really got there and
i talked to him before the draft he was
working out with julio jones because
they're both alabama guys
and i don't think he ever dreamed he'd
end up playing with julio jones but
he's going to be in that shadow as long
as julio jones is there i think he's in
the process of matching
the the stature and the performance of
julio jones he's got 130 yards in the
opener 100 and
109 yards in the second game the problem
is they're all in two
so we just write off everybody on the
falcons well he's been very good harry
gage has been very good
uh uh is it harry gage i'm thinking
harry douglas 83 every time i see 83
yeah
maybe he's even more unsung because he's
doing well too let's see
gage falcons real-time stuff as we get
into the final minute of today's show
russell gage russell russell gage is the
guy we're thinking of i'm just going to
call him harry gage
all right anyway calvin ridley unsung
hero who else did you have on your list
well i mean
i want to question that i mean it's hard
to be an unsung hero in your own two but
i
i i you're right he doesn't get the
credit i had greg zerline
for that damn onside kick i mean that
was special
uh i honestly i wrote down calais
campbell
i know he was traded and a big time
player but
sack last week tipped the ball in the
air interception got them going in week
one
his leadership everything there he had
that big play week one where he dropped
into coverage and and screwed up baker
mayfield the rest of the game i think
because makefield was
either seeing ghosts and or coleas
campbell
nowhere floworski
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure
to hit subscribe for the latest news and
highlights from nbc sports